Serbia solo sale en las noticias cuando defiende
a Novak Djokovic, ese tenista que no quiere
vacunarse.
Ahora bien: ¿a quién le importa Serbia?
Pues, sin ir más lejos, a Putin ¿Recordáis
el discurso en el que anuncia la invasión
de Ucrania?
Seguro que todos habéis visto algún extracto
del discurso.
Pues atentos a esta otra.
Primero se llevó a cabo una sangrienta operación
militar contra Belgrado, sin la aprobación
del Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU pero con
aviones de combate y misiles que fueron utilizados
en el corazón de Europa.
El bombardeo de ciudades pacíficas e infraestructura
vital se prolongó durante varias semanas.
Putin recitaba todos los agravios que Occidente
ha hecho contra los intereses de Rusia desde
la desintegración de la Unión Soviética.
En esas estaba el presidente ruso cuando mencionó
los bombardeos de Belgrado.
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos…
sobre todo los que tengáis más de 30 años…
¿Bombardeos de Belgrado?
¡Eso me suena!
¡Algo he oído hablar de eso!
Exacto, hablamos de un episodio de la Guerra
de los Balcanes, uno de los conflictos más
sanguinarios de la historia moderna.
Una guerra que se produjo en suelo Europeo
cuando casi todos los que veis VisualPolitik
habíais nacido.
Hoy en día, Serbia es un país con menos
de 7 millones de habitantes.
Nunca ha sido una superpotencia ni tiene recursos
naturales importantes.
Sin embargo, en este país es donde estalló
la Primera Guerra Mundial y… la Guerra de
los Balcanes.
Así que la pregunta que hoy os hacemos es…
¿Por qué Serbia es tan conflictiva?
¿Qué pasó en esa Guerra de los Balcanes
que todos vimos de pequeños en los telediarios?
¿Y por qué Putin lo recuerda en sus discursos?
¿Qué lazos hay entre Serbia y Rusia?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes… vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
YUGOSLAVIA, LA TIERRA DE LOS ESLAVOS DEL SUR
Durante siglos los Balcanes fueron la frontera
entre dos imperios: el austríaco y el otomano.
Fue a finales del siglo XIX cuando los serbios
se independizaron del dominio turco y proclamaron
el Reino de Serbia ¿El problema?
El problema es que los Balcanes son el hogar
de muchas etnias distintas.
Cada una con su idioma, su religión y su
sentimiento nacional.
Algunos serbios no vivían dentro del nuevo
Reino de Serbia.
Muchos vivían en Bosnia-Herzegovina, que
era una provincia dentro del imperio austrohúngaro.
Pues bien, un grupo de separatistas serbios
organizaron el atentado de Sarajevo.
El resto es historia.
En 1914 Gavrilo Princip, un nacionalista serbio,
asesinó al archiduque Francisco Fernando,
heredero al trono del Imperio Austrohúngaro.
En consecuencia Austria-Hungría declaró
la guerra al Reino de Serbia, poniendo en
marcha todas las alianzas militares que venían
tejiéndose en Europa en las últimas décadas.
De hecho la propia Rusia se vio arrastrada
al conflicto a raíz de su pacto con Serbia.
Acababa de comenzar en Sarajevo la Primera
Guerra Mundial.
Serbia estuvo del lado de los vencedores en
la Gran Guerra.
Eso supuso que el reino ampliara considerablemente
sus territorios.
Por fin era realidad una Yugoslavia independiente,
un país que aglutinara a los eslavos del
sur ¿Problema?
De nuevo: los eslavos del Sur estaban divididos
en un montón de etnias distintas.
Y no todos tenían claro que querían pertenecer
a un mismo estado.
De hecho, durante la II Guerra Mundial, los
croatas apoyaron a Hitler para poder crear
su propia Croacia independiente.
Así es como surgió uno de los regímenes
más sanguinarios de la historia: la Ustaša.
(Paréntesis: no voy a entrar en detalles
pero la Ustaša fue tan brutal que incluso
los nazis llegaron a juzgar a algunos de sus
altos mandos por crímenes contra la humanidad.
Pero eso es tema para otro vídeo).
Lo importante es que, durante la II Guerra
Mundial, los partisanos consiguieron echar
a los nazis de la zona.
Y estos partisanos, de ideología comunista,
tenían como líder a este señor que veis
en pantalla:
Josip Broz, más conocido como “Tito”.
Desde un primer momento el mariscal Tito tuvo
claro que su principal tarea era unir a los
distintos grupos nacionales en la Yugoslavia
moderna.
Así que reconoció sus derechos dando el
status de República a Bosnia-Herzegovina,
Croacia, Eslovenia, Macedonia, Montenegro
y la propia Serbia.
En la antigua Yugoslavia, la opresión nacional
por parte de la gran camarilla capitalista
serbia significó fortalecer la explotación
económica de los pueblos oprimidos.
En la nueva Yugoslavia socialista, la igualdad
de derechos existente para todas las nacionalidades
ha hecho imposible que un grupo nacional imponga
la explotación económica a otro.
Josip Broz “Tito”.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando: como buen
país comunista, Yugoslavia sería un satélite
de Moscú ¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Yugoslavia se había liberado por sí misma
gracias a la lucha de los partisanos.
Y Tito rechazaba cualquier intromisión de
Moscú.
De hecho, durante casi todo el siglo 20, los
yugoslavos eran los grandes afortunados: podían
viajar y hacer negocios con todo el mundo;
tanto capitalistas como comunistas.
Yugoslavia era una federación socialista
en la que cada república poseía su propio
parlamento y un alto nivel de autonomía.
Las decisiones que afectaban a todo el país
se tomaban de forma conjunta a través de
un consejo en el que estaba un representante
de cada república.
La Constitución yugoslava de 1974 aumentó
la autonomía dentro de la República de Serbia
de las provincias de Kosovo y de Vojvodina,
que pasaron a tener representación en el
Consejo de Yugoslavia.
Esto significaba que estas provincias autónomas
tenían el mismo poder en Yugoslavia que la
propia Serbia.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito!
En 1080 Tito murió.
Y Yugoslavia entró en una crisis económica
brutal.
Esto incluye una hiperinflación de niveles
bolivarianos.
Y claro, cuando las cosas van bien, todos
somos amigos...
Los serbios, los croatas, los eslovenos, los
kosovares...
Pero cuando van mal, crees que el gobernante
de turno solo intenta beneficiar a los suyos
y perjudicarte a ti.
A finales de los 80, Kosovo era un auténtico
polvorín.
Los serbokosovares se sentían oprimidos por
la mayoría étnica de origen albanés.
Al frente de Kosovo y de su partido comunista
estaban los albanokosovares.
El conflicto ya estaba en la calle.
Para calmar las cosas el Partido Comunista
serbio envió a su segundo de a bordo.
Y allá que fue Slobodan Milosevic.
Entonces los serbokosovares le dijeron: oye,
defiende nuestros derechos porque los albanokosovares
nos están hostigando.
Mirad.
Aquí los serbios hemos esperado desde los
días de Tito.
El Partido Comunista no ha hecho nada por
nosotros.
¡Nada!
Somos conscientes de ello en el Comité Central
de Serbia.
Podríamos hacer más.
¡Y vaya si lo hicieron!
A partir de entonces Milosevic adoptó un
nacionalismo muy popular entre la población
serbia.
En 1989 se convirtió en presidente de toda
Yugoslavia.
Una de sus primeras medidas fue eliminar la
autonomía de las provincias de Kosovo y Vojvodina,
haciéndose con sus votos en el Consejo que
gobernaba Yugoslavia.
A la vista del poder que acumulaba el nacionalismo
serbio, Eslovenia y Croacia, las repúblicas
más ricas de Yugoslavia, optaron por declarar
su independencia.
Y así es como empezó la guerra de los Balcanes.
LA GUERRA DE YUGOSLAVIA
La primera república en independizarse fue
ESLOVENIA.
En Eslovenia vivían pocos serbios así que
no hubo grandes problemas.
Por supuesto, hubo una guerra con Yugoslavia
pero duró sólo 10 días.
Sin embargo, el caso de los croatas fue muy
distinto.
Croacia sí tenía serbios viviendo en su
territorio.
Así que Belgrado envió al ejército yugoslavo
para enfrentarse a los croatas.
La guerra de la independencia croata duró
años.
Fue todo un baño de sangre.
Pero nada comparado con BOSNIA.
En este caso, hablamos de tres bandos peleaban
entre sí.
Los bosníacos, de religión musulmana, luchaban
por sobrevivir.
Los otros, azuzados por Serbia y Croacia,
querían repartirse Bosnia; eran los bosniocroatas
católicos y los serbobosnios, cristianos
ortodoxos.
Los serbo bosnios llegaron a crear su propia
república independiente: la república SRPSKA.
Aquí es donde surgió el asedio a SARAJEVO,
que seguramente os sonará a muchos por los
telediarios de vuestra infancia.
En este momento es cuando la ONU decretó
una zona de exclusión aérea ¿Y quién defendía
el espacio aéreo de Bosnia?
¡Exacto!
La OTAN.
Eso explica que en 1994, la OTAN derribase
hasta 4 aviones serbo bosnios.
Y diréis ¿Qué pensaba Rusia al respecto?
Pues lo cierto es que a duras penas protestaron.
Pensadlo bien, Yeltsin acababa de bombardear
el mismísimo parlamento ruso así que tenía
otros asuntos que atender.
Eso explica declaraciones como esta.
EL DILEMA DE BOSNIA: Yeltsin advierte a los
serbios que detengan los ataques; La tajante
declaración del líder del Kremlin muestra
un cambio de actitud hacia los aliados de
toda la vida.
Lo que pasa es que los serbobosnios son unos
tíos más duros que el adamantium de Lobezno.
No veían motivo alguno para parar la guerra.
Ni siquiera después de que los bosníacos
y los bosniocroatas unieran sus fuerzas contras
ellos.
Estaban ganando.
Pero en 1995 todo cambió.
Los bosniocroatas lograron el apoyo del Ejército
croata.
Los serbobosnios decidieron morir matando
y perpetraron entonces la masacre de Srebrenica,
el mayor genocidio de la guerra de Bosnia.
Como las cosas se estaban poniendo muy feas,
la OTAN lanzó la Operación Fuerza Deliberada:
una campaña aérea de 3 semanas que obligó
a los serbobosnios a negociar.
Los rusos protestaron pero entendieron que
era la única forma de acabar la guerra.
Así que Moscú participó junto a Occidente
en la negociación de los Acuerdos de Dayton.
Por fin los Balcanes respiraron aliviados.
Es verdad que no todos.
Para los serbios Dayton fue como el Versalles
serbio, un acuerdo humillante.
Los serbobosnios rechazan el Acuerdo de Dayton;
el tratado se ve amenazado
¡Pero la historia no termina aquí!
La calma en los Balcanes duró hasta 1998.
Empezó entonces una guerra de baja intensidad
entre las fuerzas yugoslavas y los albanokosovares,
que querían independizarse de Serbia.
Occidente castigó a Milosevic por su represión
en Kosovo mediante sanciones internacionales.
No surtieron efecto.
Así que la OTAN obligó a Belgrado a negociar
para devolver a Kosovo la autonomía.
Pero Milosevic rechazó la participación
de tropas internacionales.
Y aquí es donde llegamos a los bombardeos
de los que hablaba Vladimir Putin.
En este momento, la OTAN se vio legitimada
entonces para bombardear Yugoslavia sin el
beneplácito de la ONU.
Duraron dos meses y medio y fueron condenados
por Rusia.
Al final Milosevic se rindió y Kosovo se
convirtió en una especie de protectorado
de la ONU.
Con los años terminó declarando su independencia
con el visto bueno de Occidente.
Algo utilizado por Putin para validar la anexión
de Crimea.
Por alguna razón, las cosas que a los albaneses
de Kosovo (y les tenemos pleno respeto) se
les permitió hacer, no se permiten en Crimea
a rusos, ucranianos y tártaros de Crimea.
Una vez más, uno se pregunta por qué.
Las fuerzas rusas participaron en el contingente
internacional que ocupó Kosovo.
Pero iban por libre.
De hecho a punto estuvo de producirse el primer
choque armado entre Rusia y la OTAN cuando
los rusos se adelantaron y tomaron el aeropuerto
de Pristina.
Allí hubo más que palabras pero afortunadamente
nadie disparó primero.
Desde entonces los Balcanes han aguantado
en un frágil equilibrio de fuerzas que podría
desestabilizarse en cualquier momento.
Y más con lo que está pasando en Ucrania.
Atentos.
LOS AMIGOS DE RUSIA
La invasión de Crimea nos enseñó algo que
parecía imposible: que los mapas de Europa
pueden cambiar en cualquier momento.
Desde entonces Serbia ha aumentado su inversión
en Defensa un 70%, hasta los 1.400 millones
de dólares al año.
¿Casualidad?
En VisualPolitik sabemos que no.
Esto es como el Paris Saint-Germain en el
futbol.
No te gastas una millonada para luego no presumir
de poderío.
Serbia acaba de encargar a Airbus dos C295.
Anteriormente negoció con Israel la adquisición
de misiles antitanque y con Turquía los drones
a los que Azerbaiyán sacó tanto partido
para derrotar a Armenia en Nagorno-Karabaj.
También ha comprado drones de combate chinos,
helicópteros rusos y un sistema francés
de misiles tierra-aire.
Además, en los últimos años Rusia y Bielorrusia
le han donado 10 cazas MIG-29.
Y el Kremlin también le regaló 30 tanques
y vehículos blindados de transporte de personal
al tiempo que le vendía un sistema de defensa
aérea.
A ver, con esto no os penséis que queremos
decir: ¡mirad que malos son los serbios!
Porque Estados Unidos también le ha dado
helicópteros Black Hawk a Croacia.
Lo que queremos es reflejar que sí, durante
dos décadas los países que integraron la
antigua Yugoslavia han intentado reconstruirse.
Algunos mejor que otros.
Pero también se están rearmando.
Y Serbia se está gastando más en su Ejército
que Albania, Bosnia, Montenegro, Kosovo y
Macedonia del Norte juntas.
Por sí solo esto no significaría nada.
El problema es que ya hay señales en la región
de que la tensión está en aumento.
El pasado otoño, por una discrepancia menor
con Kosovo, Belgrado envió aviones de guerra
cerca de la frontera y desplegó vehículos
blindados para intimidar a su antigua provincia.
Pero pensando en las guerras del pasado, resulta
más preocupante el auge del discurso nacionalista
dentro del Gobierno serbio.
Escuchad a su ministro del Interior, Aleksander
Vulin, en la llamada Asamblea de todos los
serbios que se celebró a finales de mayo:
Los serbios debemos ser un pueblo político
unido
Las alusiones a crear un “mundo serbio”
son vistas con recelo por todos los países
de la zona donde hay una comunidad importante
de serbios.
Hay miedo a que esta idea de una Gran Serbia
provoque la vuelta de las armas.
En cualquier caso, hay que diferenciar que
una cosa es que Serbia no quiera imponer sanciones
a la Rusia de Putin; o que incluso haya aprovechado
la situación para obtener un acuerdo de suministro
de gas ruso en condiciones muy ventajosas.
Y otra cosa muy diferente es que Serbia vaya
a tomar la iniciativa.
Pero sobre esto, sobre la situación actual
de Serbia, sus relaciones con Rusia y también
con la Unión Europea, os vamos a hablar en
otro vídeo muy pronto.
Estad atentos porque seguro que muchas cosas
os van a sorprender de este extraño país
balcánico.
Oficialmente en Belgrado siguen queriendo
entrar en la Unión Europea.
Y el país está prácticamente rodeado por
la OTAN.
Salvo por un lugar: Bosnia-Herzegovina.
Un estado federal en el que la República
Srpska es una entidad propia.
De Bosnia hablaremos pronto aquí, en VisualPolitik,
porque es un país muy especial.
Un país con tres presidentes distintos.
Y allí Milorad Dodik, el líder de los serbobosnios
ha elevado el tono.
Amenaza con romper el país.
Lo viene haciendo desde que el pasado otoño
se reunió con el ministro ruso de Exteriores.
De aquella reunión salieron informaciones
de que los serbobosnios habían pedido ayuda
armamentística a Moscú.
Escuchad lo que dice Milorad Dodik sobre la
independencia de la Republica Srpska.
Si la OTAN interviene, pediremos ayuda a nuestros
amigos que nos han dicho, alto y claro, que
nunca defraudan a sus amigos.
Otra guerra en Europa sería una forma de
desestabilizar a Occidente.
Con Rusia golpeada de forma tan contundente
por las sanciones, no podemos descartar que
el Kremlin haya puesto Bosnia en su punto
de mira.
También es verdad que, de toda esta historia
de cómo se desintegró la antigua Yugoslavia,
hay una auténtica víctima que son los bosnios.
Pero, como ya os he dicho, de esto hablaremos
en otro vídeo.
Porque ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Creéis que Rusia está dispuesta a reabrir
viejas heridas en los Balcanes?
¿Veis posible que vuelva a estallar la guerra
en lo que fue la antigua Yugoslavia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.